five I was thinking but then queen of
three was a problem originally I thought
um you know he doesn't have the queen of
three move but he does have the movement
after this is very complicated he has a
very big initiative and I didn't really
feel like it's worth going for that so
that's why I played Bishop a5 indeed
Bishop f5 was absolutely the strongest
move we were really really shocked you
know the way you were just blitzing out
the moves it looked like you had this
all planned and then you finally played
rook to da there were different ways to
win instead of her to da you could have
also played at age 4 what would happen I
wasn't so sure if he would have played
after Bishop a5 if he would have played
h3 I wasn't sure what what I what was
happening Bishop f5 I think h3 is bad
for him as well I must have missed
something then there 64 ok H takes e4
all Queen b6 you know I didn't I didn't
see Queen b6 that's told him that when
that's a very nice move Wow because
after Queen takes d4 Queen text of 2 and
htv-4 no I completely missed that movie
I did not see it in a given time sure
it's very card not obvious move at all I
mean I was probably thinking about the
ship c6 or Bishop g6 this move didn't
even I didn't even consider that move I
know so Queen b6 is a typical computer
move I out say I'll probably not see it
and it would probably be roughly equal
games so I was surprised that he didn't
play h3 because I thought the other
thing that he did I just have all the
initiative Wow
so yeah sure said sometimes it pays to
be lucky and I guess in this case he's
right maybe he saw the move Queen b6 and
that's why he avoided the line yeah he
was in terrific time pressure but then
at some point the game started going
back and forth a little bit you were up
in exchange but it wasn't clear that you
were just ramming home your advantage
were you worried that you had blown it
at some point
III didn't think that I blown it but I
knew it's gonna be very difficult and I
knew knots relax I I knew that I would
have to show good technique to win it
because as we know yesterday I got very
lucky you know my opponent blew a
completely winning position because she
probably thought he's winning no matter
what almost and I didn't want to make
the same mistake as my opponent did
yesterday great
so it was very important that I I had a
lot of time you know it was very
important that I take my time and find
the best plan because when you're
waiting a special an end you might
always tell all the kids and students
not to ever rush so that's the time you
just gotta buckle down and find the best
plan fantastic advice you're the sole
leader of the u.s. championship right
now you have two and a half points by
yourself what do you do to stay focus on
the job at hand there's still eight
rounds to go I'll just take it one one
one move at a time one game at a time
it's obviously a very long tournament
it's early to draw any conclusions and
in fact I could have easily had one and
a half out of three but I'll take it and
like I said one step at a time and try
to prepare for a tomorrow fantastic
advice and you just mentioned ray Robson
who was your co-leader who drew against
Kamsky this last round
what are your what's your history
matchup with him and what do you do to
really play powerful chest well he's a
very good player so I have to be at my
best egg I have to bring my a-game and
hope for the best
just battlin do my best what's your
history with him do you oh well we've
played quite a few times but as of
recently well I have a 1 in the u.s.
championship two years ago against him
and then I drew against him in Chicago
and then we played two games a long
while ago and he beat me one game there
but you know he we were both in the u.s.
juniors so no I I know he's a very good
player he's a rapidly improving player
as well so it's it's gonna be a very
tough game you're a little kid back then
you're an old man now well he was even
younger so was advantage came to what we
wish you the best of luck in tomorrow's
game and in the rest of the championship
thank you very much
Grandmaster Alex Lenderman hailing from
Brooklyn let me just add again leading
the tournament two and a half points
great place to be back to you guys Thank
You Maurice a very impressive start for
Alex there with two and a half points
he's making victories look easy and I
see our us champion gata Kamsky
struggling to even get a victory and we
do have just a few games left
yes of this problem pretty soon it looks
like well grave is wrapping up this end
game against arid it's good the pawns
are actually equal but boy White's King
is gonna be an f5 the bishops gonna go
to half for the pawns bento at age 6 and
that's not going to be fun for black no
saving that one mm oh that was a nice
technique I think he gave up his 8 Ponte
trade rooks and now he just walks his
King up and it looks like he's walking
somewhere else
yes yes so and in the other games this
game is over and it looks like Anna's
gonna win any second if they're still
playing and as the time this looks like
she's many many ones up with a nice King
and nice pass pawn and rook so oh sorry
that is a rook on g3 I apologize I
thought she was just gonna be a rook and
it does look indeed you called it right
there signing the scoresheet so this
means Anna's tied for first with I read
the question then write her up to two
and a half points and the other games
been so there we're getting results
coming in fast and furious
how about the Tamila really surprising
as I wanted to look at touches game
because because there's been no move
since the time control after this
discovered check possibility mm-hmm
instead not moving at all and I think
she's used 20 minutes and still hasn't
made a move Wow Wow so that game is on
freeze mode at the moment yeah and yeah
it looks like if there's not a good
discovered check it's just gonna be good
for Wyatt absolutely that pawn on a that
a fight on going to a6 is going to put
Nemcova and a lot of trouble and then
the game yes participant I was this very
curious if this seems to be a missing d5
pawn there is no there seems to be a
nice H point here for white also okay
well I got a like white passed pawns on
both sides of the board I know but I
don't know sometimes the King can jump
to come to c3 and
maybe deep pongos or beep on goes
so you think blacks getting some
counterplay mm I think you can be
calculated you know move on move type of
thing I'm sure I prefer to be white I
mean past a pawn past H pawn as your
graphic shows I can play Queen g6 and
then just start pushing my H pawn yeah
but I wouldn't I wouldn't say that this
is cut and dried simple simple simple
I'd still think that Camilla might be
done yes a little bit work up to and
speaking of a good worker
we do have team work art and Getty up in
our studio he is standing by with
Maurice to share with us his thoughts of
how he won today Maurice with the number
two seed in the tournament some more
gray of first of all congratulations and
thanks for coming on our show yeah thank
you now Seymour you had a completely
winning position yesterday
not to remind you of bad news I just I
just heard Alex I so indeed you had a
winning position yesterday and how did
you come back after that disappointment
to play this game today oh I was pretty
terrible huh and plus I was super tired
I guess I was a combination of you know
just you know spending a lot of energy
I'm not winning the game I mean really
if you look at the variations I mean III
had a an idea in mind that was better
than what I played but whatever you can
kind of you can't just play perfect did
you did you sleep badly last night I
mean did you do I played an excellent
game up to that point up to the point
when I you know made the mistake you
know about oh yeah it's nice to win
today you know it's the first victory
and I'll clean it up absolutely that's
what I was curious to know what you did
because a lot of us go through that not
win a game and have to deal with a game
the next day what do you get angry do
you just get it out your mind what do
you what do you do and he techniques
watch watch a movie maybe all right how
do you clear your brain so you re the
next day actually yeah true you know I
was just uh you know just trying to - do
you know in the past few days I was you
know trying to push myself a little bit
you know exercise more you know do
today I was just I just figured I need
more rest I was just sleeping more and
then I was lying down more than just you
know watching some videos online news to
make it a little more simple and then
you know I showed up a little more
relaxed and you know I guess my opponent
you know now it's it's key and missed a
couple opportunities he his opening
certainly was promising despite the fact
that my position looks really solid and
advanced I think he missed a couple of
opportunities allowing me to just keep
going forward and it was surprising that
you know going forward that hard I
wasn't getting him right away
and then he just kept getting going
tactical and you know I was just know in
no mood to you know complicate things so
I was just trying to simplify position
and eventually I guess in a way lucky
for me on the other hand I mean I
certainly have you know some big
positional advantage the bishop is stuck
on g7 and you know well they say luck
goes to the strong so you obviously get
to make your oh yeah as well can't be
unlucky every city I can't be on like
every time I hahaha he resigned in this
position I'd like you to take take the
folks through the following moves to see
why exactly did he resign at this moment
just give us a couple of reasons why
well I guess you know this position kind
of represents what I've been aiming to
accomplish in in the past 20 moves or
even more I guess maybe 30 moves but I
think that was what was really cool is
for me to get let's see from about the
position with I guess yeah that's not
that much of an advantage I mean it's
close to one point mm-hmm and then right
about here I mean I get even here it's
not that big I mean yesterday I had plus
three here but you know you can see that
you know black is just hopeless here in
in positional sense but then you know
there's no why's that
just just so well explained to the
audience here so just in terms of
resources you can see that the King is
restricted the King can go here because
you know there's a pond on H five the
King cannot go through h6 because
there's a bishop here so how is the king
getting through so it's not getting
through yeah that's definitely true so I
was working to actually okay you through
opposition or I got to find your game
back here we go yeah I guess oh yeah
that's definitely if my king is on d3
the the evaluation would be plus three
you know you know and then I also have
the weak point on b3 I'm getting the
pawn on a five
so there's tactical uncertainty but very
slight uncertainty because you know I
was still strategically I'm pursuing
same goals and you have great pawns are
certainly the isolated pawns they're
restricting black selects so if black
doesn't have counter play that's when I
you know basically my opponent has to
resign so and that's kind of when we
reach this position my opponent doesn't
have much counter play because my king
is is coming through towards III and f5
picking out the pawn both of this pawns
are in dark squares accessible for my
bishop and there's this killer pawn on H
that's going forward which I can move it
any point that I like my King can
penetrate from e6 and g6 so it's just
totally crushing Pollak crushing very
clear you explained right there thank
you so much so you got your win right
now you got a win how do you feel now
moving forward in the championship and
it's certainly not yesterday today now
it should be a brighter day oh well you
know it's it's nice to get more wins the
first time would have been nicer to have
two wins but I was actually looking
looking five Arrington I'm very happy
with the colors you know I just kind of
looked at it briefly and I was pretty
happy with who do you play tomorrow I
think Mackenzie I think I think so so
yeah I just just get more victories but
it's 11 rounds you know so we're only
done two games god I still warming up
you know that's the way he's gonna keep
going for a while you know we'll see I
mean it's even hard to think about
opponents of potential competition or
the really the DD what I gotta do
essentially is just play the best game
myself you know hey as we can see
anybody can get hot and start winning
games so thanks so much for your time
and we wish you the best in the rest of
the game yeah thank you very much rap
master two more grave now on plus one
and looking to go back to you guys
Q Maurice Thank You team or indeed I
thought that was a very nice impressive
decree by team or final position was
totally went one as was explained that
was just no fun for black after six no
just passive the rest of the way
just a small regret that Maurice didn't
take him to the mat there and ask him
what about that Knight d7 position
because that moved ninety-seven I think
would have given Daniel if you don't
mind been just drinking that one
position up on our board for a moment
because I think that that move ninety
seven really deserved attention this
came after the f5 move was thrown in and
this was the moment where Daniel
probably missed his best chance by not
playing the move ninety seven had he did
have had he made that move I think it
would I
all three results would have been
possible let's just put it that way
all right where we're right we're
wrapping up the round three today I
again I do promise you that we will be
airing the interview with Rexach Theo it
will be air tomorrow and probably a
little bit before the show starts but
we'll find a good time slot it's a
wonderful interview by the way Rex
really his humor shines through and if
you with Rex it fuels is a great
Mother's Day present for anybody I'm not
so sure
unless you're a Yankees fan
there you go but speaking of mother's
day that's coming tomorrow one of our
co-leaders in the Women's Championship
is none other than four-time winner and
as a Tomsky and she's with Maryse and
she's really happy well we got Mother's
Day tomorrow and she's a mom so she gets
the rest day which would be nice to shop
for her mom and she said shop for her
daughter as well so congratulations on
your victory today thank you
now it was tough the first round you had
some work now you've won two in a row
like what's what's got you warming up in
this championship I don't know I think
it's just first round it's always
difficult to play for me somehow or even
if I'm winning I'm not getting another a
promising position it's first round it's
kind of by transitions for me I see you
played against Sabina Poyser she was on
tour no was just a big game for you did
you feel like you really had to lay the
hammer down you're going for the win
right from the start because yesterday
she had losing position it's not like
she demolished everyone in this
tournament and of course so I try to
play some sharp variations and when I
was preparing I tried to avoid some
lines where I changed all pieces and I
don't know I don't know I tried to play
for winner from my first two moves
because I think I had to win this game
you think you had to win this yes and
why so I have good score and I think I
don't know if or she is good in good
shape or not but she yesterday she
didn't play very good so I thought I
just blend better and indeed so at some
point though there were some funny time
pressure issues it looked like right
from the opening there you guys were
sitting there and moved 13 or so with
very little time maybe I can explain why
I couldn't let's go have to move d5 so I
think we're going here ya know before
when I play d5 I'll move for even you
know for clarify for all my life I
played here castle
and of course I'm playing many other
openings like winds gambit and some
other variations and I prepared move d5
and I did not know my toaster I think
it's a rare move at least it I was not
aware of this move that's what all our
d4 players are saying here to them oh
yes yes so and I would think I should I
play quiet here or c5 and of course so
this is just natural feel and when you
see such move Knight after which you
didn't expect you want to play quite
variation you don't want to go to a
sharp line after c5 and I had to make
decision now to castle or place if I
throw some concrete lines and without
any knowledge so but I thinks if I was a
good move right well I think Houdini
agrees with you that c5 seems like a
good way to play seems like no advantage
for her so that cost you a lot of time
that must have burned her a lot of time
as well and then later the game got
really complicated and right out of the
opening and probably I would like to
point out that she might some
psychological mistake so I'll probably
move efore could you please go connect
sure it's okay maybe instead of E for
was interesting to play Bishop age 4
yes Bishop age 4 of course I'm winnin
pawn I'm winnin ponen a3 but she will
have compensation and keeping Queens on
board were important thinking how severe
my pressure my time pressure was already
on move 11 I think I had here maybe 25
minutes and maintain intention it was
important for her because after if or
after afore we exchanged Queens and it
was very easy for me to find moves
spoken like a true veteran looks like
you've played in this once or twice so
you get a rest day tomorrow
you said you were gonna shop for your
mom on the rest day what about your
children do they get to shop for you
soon ok so he is 7 years old well we
hope you enjoy the rest day
congratulations oh one last thing
you know it seems like a horse race a
two horse race all the time
now you are tied with your main rival
who has drawn her game today what are
you thinking what are your thoughts
about that you guys meet late in round 8
of the competition how do you feel about
the next rounds going forward okay so
I'm pretty happy that at least I'm
winning games and I'm playing better
chess I think then in first round and
there is still more round and strong
opponents minister on opponents and I
think we will lose points
I'm British rubber will lose some points
before we'll meet each other and right
now I'm concentrating on my future games
and professional attitude well
congratulations on your win today and
best of luck in the rest of the games
thank you four-time champion and as a
tone ski tied for first she's known this
position before we'll see how the
competition heats up in round 4 of the
championship back to you guys Thank You
Maurice and thank you honor because
autumn made a very good point she didn't
she used the term psychological but and
in actuality we saw it yesterday in the
game between Sam Shanklin and Ray Robson
or essentially ray got into really
big-time trouble and then Sam basically
hoovered the pieces off the board and
loud him ray that is to make a draw in
this game sabine with their opponent
under severe time trouble came up with
his movie for there was lots of trees
and there was lots of precisely and
that's something that just tournament
players competitive tournament players
have to keep in mind don't let your
opponent
don't help your opponent solve their
problems by trading off the pieces when
they're in time trouble we've had a
glitch I think in the game of totty EV
not too many moves have come through on
our side here in in the club we can see
the moves have been played they haven't
really been there was a very unusual
move made after the time control she
played III which wasn't what I was
expecting in this position e4 III no
discovered checks but II for
tatta have just checked and picked up
the pawn so it looks like a good deal
yeah okay this is the current position
issue right so III she just she just
checked and picked up the pawn hold let
me let me and I'll copy the game again
alright so you can get up to date yeah
we know the movie 14 Jack Queen check
and just took the pawn right because
Knight d5 yeah 95 running g3 and queen
g3 no prob was just a pawn ahead right
so after Queen takes III we have seen
what move I think she played them of c5
getting her own past pun but now the
apon Tatia mas White must be winning
this position because she's a pawn to
the good to begin with so she's here
this Kings a little exposed here there's
a lot of space around and the a pawn is
far more dangerous than the C pawn so I
think Totti F is well on her way to
winning against catchin em Cova a so big
big time advantage also 17 minutes to
seven it took off a long time but she
really didn't find anything good it was
that again it's the time trouble at the
end of the first time control I thought
black was playing really good game she
had a queen on d1 pinning white up
wasn't really doing the aggressive just
checking back and forth trying to get to
move and just hanging on not to lose a
piece actually you remember she had he
chase her queen all the way to a6 big
turnaround in this game and besides this
game can we see the game of Camilla
against our young 13 year old phenom who
we think is winning with white but made
it a little bit difficult for herself
she had missed that beautiful move
85 not the first move that comes to mind
right yeah I should have made a lot of
moves oh my since moves that have been
made at my swing would came to d4 yep
okay so we have Queen g6 which I suggest
is that a good sign so Queen DOS luckily
those of you at home they can't see all
the head shaking here well I thought
Queenie the h1 was a good idea okay I've
had worse ideas and after Queen g6 Queen
d5 was played this is the discovered
check day right everybody wants to play
for discovered check right and I guess
Black has a couple of ideas not only
your idea of king c3 attacking this upon
may be using this King to stop the a
pawn and attacking the pawn with the
Queen so black has lots of ideas right
so Queen d5 this isn't a simple endgame
at all Queen to g7 Chuck that stops us
from I think it was time to wow I don't
know I'm pretty sure I don't like the
move Queen g7 check because she's three
check oh she is just forcing Camila's
King to a much better Square
so she's losing the threat a bit here s
Warren I really love just losing the
thread that I like these moves yeah I
agree and where do we currently stand
out there still trying to get to the
position okay King c2
okay and now she blocks the e pawn with
Queen to e3 but my goodness big big
pretty defensive yeah but big
improvement for black because the black
Queen first of all is on d5 which covers
the fifth ring protecting against both
white pawn advances the King blacks King
has beautiful beautifully positioned on
c2 you can't expect a third she rolls
have a lot of experience in Queen and
pawn and gamers know that's not
something you get as a kid all I know
you don't that is true now Camilla
wanted to Queen her D pawn so she played
Queen to e5 okay she's sneaking away for
her D pawn to run down the board with
tempo I might add and by the way they
very nicely supported by the King on a
c2 this comes to mind a game that you
had against Frederick nickel it's worth
I think you were down three pawns of the
queen of money which would ruin you
you had the one pass bond that's all you
need to do right right but this is even
better for blacks and your again because
blacks only down one pawn it's and now
Queen g5 trying to get to one of these
winning King apartment and won games but
is that even even is that well okay it
sounds like if we take and try to win
this this one is just too strong too
fast
yes okay they've played one more move
after Queens g5 Queen to d4 mm-hmm and
now white finally got her pawn going h5
yay although the queening squares
defended right this point is hanging are
all three results possible no I think
it's more like a draw or a win for white
still s Warren I think has had trouble
real light what we would say poor
technique yeah I think that really helps
black getting her King down the board
rather than was on e6 and II 5 this is
much better
big time well we just heard Timur a top
world-class Grandmaster explaining about
counter play and the necessity and the
ending of having an active King and this
is a shining example of what kind of
counter play can be produced
have we seen King takes b3 by the way
because I was kind of thinking about the
line King takes b3 he takes b3 was
played and by the way two minutes for
kamila 26 minutes for youngish run all
right and I was anticipating h6 why not
King c2 why not h7 b3 go baby go but
white I was I thought was going to be
too fast after Queen g8 I'm not sure
Queen g8 8v - what else right do I have
any reasons to trick you with some check
at the moment don't trick me this is my
first day these tricks do you know about
the $64,000 best comments prize I can't
win that I missed the first two days
okay that's true well this was important
Maurice let me get you involved in this
discussion we are having a lot of fun in
this Queen ending let me throw it to
Murray Grandmaster Maurice Ashley to get
his take
well these Queen endings are never fun I
remember way back when am I going back
to like 89 whoa way back when when I
lost one of these to a grandmaster
dmitriyevitch I was not I was not even
an international master yet New York
open it took 8 hours we were the only
ones that left in the playing hall
except my good buddy
Willie Johnson who was sitting there
commiserating he was like dude I was a
pawn down and the GM melted me too in
the morning when I lost that game 8
hours long this stuff is rough and even
now it gets no easier even after I've
studied these endings it's not easy to
decide what the best moves are and guys
I have to tell you even you're wrong
unfortunately the computer is saying
Queen g6 was not the most accurate move
in fact the most accurate move was Queen
to g7 so that after King down stopping
the came from going to c3 playing the
move Queen to g5 getting the pawn going
forward immediately with tempo and that
this would have been a better way for
her to go by the way it doesn't mean
anything as far as games over or winning
the computer agrees that this is a very
difficult ending to play she blew it a
long time ago when she should have
played that move a5 now she's really got
to work it out for her the good news is
this ending is extremely complex none of
us can really figure it out every move
is on as razor's edge and at this point
here that we have this position sorry we
have this position in the game and white
trying to make progress it's a difficult
position to continue well let me get the
main line up first excuse me guys all
right so we're here now it's difficult
for black blacks and time pressure and
black had some drawing chances trying to
get at this King but it turns out those
chances have evaporated a bit she has to
find the right move
those precise moves now with one minute
and 22 seconds on her clock to try to
draw any move that's off could give
white an easy queen look at this a
Queens coming up really soon but she
does have this move Queen to d5 if she
finds it not the hardest move in the
world to find then this pawn push
doesn't lead anywhere after this
discovered check finally getting in
where she can push her own pawn forward
and take a look at this position that
Queens arriving on the board to Queens
and she can get another Queen but try to
calculate this mess the computer says
it's slightly better for black it's
White's move it's White's move to Queens
but there's no mate no matter how hard
you try there's no mate so crazy
position and Camilla is gonna have to
calculate this this is a mess and we'll
see whether or not the youngster goes
into this line and she has found the
move Queen d5 so suddenly we can get
that for Queens position on the board
you know they look so calm guy he looks
so calm you know this churning inside
time pressure u.s. Women's Championship
amazing situation we'll see what happens
in the next few minutes back to you guys
that it Thank You Maurice that's an
extraordinary line I mean I have had a
career of more than 4,000 tournament
games and I think in my entire career
I've only experienced one game where
there were four Queens on the board here
we have the thirteen-year-old are--this
Warren and bang up against one of the
most experienced veterans in the term
women's tournaments Camilla and Wow that
was wild what a wild variation of the
game that I annotated for for our
website here her first game which was a
real up-and-down affair and really long
complicated ending she's gonna get a lot
of experience this tournament house talk
about compressing a careers worth of
experience into a single event but we do
have another result yeah Tatsu I've
actually played quite well here and one
quickly
sohave g3 very strong move
attacking the night oh yeah and this got
out of all the discovered checks we've
been we've been waiting for but yeah
none of them seemed to happen black
played Knight g6 that's not that's a
pretty sorry retreat and the game ended
actually very quickly a six all right it
looks like the pawns just go go Queen
Namco vote played Queen c7 but was
preventing a7 a very short defense the
game ended in just two moves Queen a3
threatening a7 to advance clean a7 and
now B - Jasser finds the winning move of
Queen B - check followed by Queen b7
clear and checkmating blacks Queen and
it's amazing the knight on a 3 which was
stuck for so many moves finally went to
sea for allowing the discovered check
the word he could discover checks yeah
yeah yeah well I'm sure Nemcova is going
to be very disappointed with the outcome
of this game because he was doing so
well just to finish the yeah f king g8
or king a queen b7 and we noticed that
after trading Queens Queens xb-70
there's no way that black's knight could
stop this pawn from promoting new queen
game over
so Nemcova very disappointed I'm sure
with the result because she was was
baffling right right up to that time
control where things went well just
there yeah and we do have taught EF
joining us and joining us in our studio
to explain this most complicated and
complex battle by the way what is the
tournament standings and honor at plus-2
was two points is she just a half a
point behind very good very good
all right we're having set up the
standings let us turn to Maurice and his
guest chef Maurice
we're with Tata vibrato hyun-jung
Abraha me on we always get that wrong
somehow you know I'm getting gases
disease it's the struggle to get through
but Tata have we like to say and
congratulations on your win was it a
dominant victory all the way through no
I think I was getting outplayed at some
point and actually I was really mad at
myself because I got into a really bad
time trouble like right out of the
opening totally unreasonable so I'm
gonna try to fix that now why did that
happen I don't know it's just this
tournament
sometimes I returned everything some
season sometimes I returned I just can't
find wolves it's a championship and yeah
this is not your first rodeo you've been
here before I know but like sometimes
some games that just feel like
everything's feels like it's so easy to
find most of things like flowing Keisel
and sometimes like my game yesterday was
so hard to find like impossible finals
thank everyone was a struggle now was
yesterday's game on your mind going into
this round no I mean yesterday's game I
thought I played better yesterday than I
did today actually really I mean I don't
think it was a bad game just I made
mistake at some critical points d ptosis
so you were you surprised at this point
when you've suddenly had a winning
position everything looked okay it looks
like a draw or maybe chances and then
all of a sudden you were there
especially at the time control I believe
had move 40 when she allowed you to play
nice c4 I mean we're in such time
trouble I mean I didn't really have time
to evaluate what's going on I'm just
like trying to make more time to make
time and actually I did I played Queen
Acer and Queeny Queeny so and see where
her king's gonna go because now 94 like
if their queen is on first and nights
before she can take on that phone
because 95 check I just kind of wanted
to see what she's gonna do and then all
of a sudden like stumbled upon this
position that's like a happy mistake a 5
maybe I have some chances because a pun
can really start moving indeed you have
now two points and the leaders right
ahead of you have two and a half we
talked about you is being a two and a
half horse race and how they are odds
gonna have what do you do now I mean
it's you know there's they're totally in
striking distance
how do you handle the games going
forward I mean there's really nothing I
mean doesn't really make a difference
all I can control is my games I mean I
really love SWANA so there's nothing I
can do about that anymore so she wants
the rest of the games and it doesn't
matter who do you play next I'm not sure
I haven't checked so looking play arena
in round five however so I think I'm
white against her so definitely not
tomorrow so so maybe I'm playing the
other Aaron so in some some opportunity
there like you said you can't control
your destiny on Owen's all her games but
that's highly unlikely in the tournament
I mean has that happened before no
indeed well congratulations on your win
we wish him best of luck in the rest of
your games
thank you dr. Barbara me on after
winning her game in good spirits going
into the rest day back to you guys
Thank You Maurice and I can't help but
reflect upon the irony of that our 13
year old in round one playing an 83 mu
game against Victoria to win it and [ __ ]
here she is with the veteran Camilla the
last game in the competition's to be
finished and talk about tech getting a
test been 13 years old playing more
moves than anybody and she was so calm
and she looks so calm and it's such a
wild position on the board so h7 was
played look at this three check III
discovered check blacks going for Queen
herself
well Camilla was one minute on her clock
looks pretty calm if I had one minute
here I'd be a little bit nervous
well fortunately she's giving a check
what Ben I can s waarom do she can
advance her F pawn to block the check
with a pawn or move her King what do you
what I'm doing today and I'm not playing
this is wild that they could very easily
turn into one of those positions that
Marissa presented us with a for Queens
and she's
reaching for this war on this year and
she has played the move King G 2 2 G 3
she has played that move Camilla to play
down to a minute and 20 odd seconds to
26 minutes for a shritha that's four Wow
play any move here for either side it
seems like it's really on the precipice
of of winning draw craziness so how
about e3 e2 put that move on you're on
our screen because one past pond
deserves another
and she's has played Camilla has played
that move
picking up slowly these chestnuts have
extra Queens yes yes the houseless
tonton provides these really beautiful
GGG enabled chess sets and it they're
really really handsome the players love
them shall we look at the line with both
sides getting between everybody
everybody loves the Queen and normally
when it's your turn to play you're
looking good exactly but I'm looking at
this queen bee to check type of business
and I hear they go I see cleans have
landed the Queen's have landed wow this
is crazy crazy joint do we have the Four
Queens engine the Four Queens engine how
about queen bee to check then King
basically has to go to d3 let's just
sure pop that and now does white have a
good and another good move I'd I'm
thinking if you go Queen h7 check I
could just go King c4 and I don't see I
think Queen B to check was played Queen
B to watch it was played okay I'm
thinking after King c4 I've got this
Queen e1 to c3 a few to interpose I have
three right and then I if Queen c2 check
I have Queen c3 check
you know the sprite commercials they
really would be two people playing a
game of chess in the park and they both
have their sprite and one player one
actor would would say check to the other
player and the player was going okay
check well check to you and then it
would be this is one of those check
check situations for Queens by the way I
meant to ask you have you been in a game
with four Queens or and you're a very
experienced tournament competitor if I
have actually can't remember I don't
think I've had a slow tournament game
where we've each had two queens right so
yeah I think I would remember if I did
is that you just don't just doesn't
happen very often
Wow so give us the current position if
you will let's go back and since my my
my attempts to analyze this ending are
gonna be futile I'm gonna toss it back
to Maryse and say you know bail is out
of this one Maryse because this one is
too wild too wild too many possibilities
impossible to go after Queen B - well
you know this stuff is easy for me right
I mean for Queens what's the big deal
dude
the computer is saying that the position
is equal that it's even then there's no
way for white to win there's no way for
black to win it's just a perpetual check
situation white has no advantage that
monster queen on d5 is the reason it's
just holding court every which way this
last check played by the young
thirteen-year-old can be responded to by
that Queen move Queen to d5 is saying
this is actually the best way to play
simplify the position a little bit and
go into an endgame with only two queens
that we're used to the problem though
with the move King to c4 is that that
gives white a few more ghost checks not
that white is winning but it thinks
white is slightly better here and
suddenly you might have some problems
you can bring your King back to d3
because of the move Queen down and oops
that's a nasty made to happen so you'd
have to play the
queen away from that central square to
c5 and then you start getting hunted a
little bit it's the positions a little
bit looser now so this is not something
she wants to do she would like to
instead play this move she needs to find
so that she doesn't get into any
difficulty and now the engine is saying
that blacks actually slightly better I
guess because of this aggressive King
this pawn is no longer the beast that it
was before and the b-pawn is kind of
strong it's still a draw basically the
position should be equal Camilla will be
relieved that she escaped from this
position but certainly she's got to be
thinking that maybe she can win and it
looks like a different move was played
let's see if we can catch up with the
position on the board after Queen B to
check let me see if I can find here the
position my game is my board is not
updating just yet so let's see if we can
get that to refresh Queen B to check is
still on the board here for me let's
take a look at the board there and see
if you guys can tell what happened in
the game after check all it did happen
Queen eight seven Czech Queen to e4 and
then she played a queen check on B three
that's what happened alright so let's
get to that Queen check King King up
Queen Queen queen e4 then she played
Queen b3 check and unfortunately we four
was played Queen c3 was apparently much
better for black what is that she played
King 2 before and now a mate in 3 was
possible there was a mate oh my goodness
she could have made it her with Queen a7
check only move Queen g7 check only move
and Queen f7 mates
she missed mate in 3 with the Queen's
incredibly and instead now after this
check King d4 he said she traded Queens
and this is the line now but it says
that she's still winning because she's
going to be able to trade Queens look at
this no matter what she's going to pick
off this pawn because
King takes is unplayable because of this
check the youngster has found a
different wind she missed the mate but
if Queen takes he or she could take this
pawn and she's winning she's winning
anyway incredible turn of events
it looks like the thirteen-year-old is
gonna pull off the victory amazing guys
well when you were telling me Maurice
that the computer thought that game was
a draw I was saying no no no way
because it was just so complicated and
and it was so easy to make an error and
there you see us s war on playing very
quickly because she's she has her
victory inside she's gonna win the game
when she smell of this Queen takes you
for was winning I always look for me
when there was an easy Queen opponent
England but it's terrible that Camilla
missed that mu queen c3 which not only
blocks the check but it sets up a
counter opportunity for Jackie and had
she found that move then
Camilla might have been the winner in
this game a really wild weight wild
turnaround going here just moved her
Queen while her King was in check she
moved her Queen yeah
while in check and and now she's she's
flustered because the because the
ashrita said your king is in check still
so that the arbiter had to come over
because she's not she moved I'm not sure
if she pressed the clock but now and and
now she's agreed to make a different
move I'm not sure what the arbiters are
going to do she hasn't resigned yet but
she was shaking her head really
flustered and what had just happened I
think that Camilla and made Queen takes
Ethan wanted resign Queen takes e4 Queen
takes b4 check and then Camilla made a
check forgetting that her king was in
check oh my goodness so a dramatic
dramatic she resign instead
her illegal move she decided to resign
and just shake her head but she was lost
anyway Wow a dramatic finish in round
three just before the freedom to recover
after around like this and the 13 year
old phenom s Warren two out of three
only only a half a point behind the two
perennial victor winners arena crush and
anna's atomic she's tied for third with
Tata and sabina voice or wow wow
fantastic result and fascinating two in
both tournaments whoo great chess Rach s
and again I do apologize I'm a terrible
host
I've been following some of your
Twitter's again we want to give the
chess comm diamond memberships to those
of you who've given us your best
comments and suggestions and ideas I
promise you that when Jennifer returns
she'll be the one handing them out very
hard for me to determine what is the
best Twitter but then remarkable thank
you for today's and game analysis if you
don't mind if you could just put that
key moment on the board so our viewers
could see this was the critical position
crucial now I suspect what happened is
Camila may have seen the move Queen C 3
if you could put that move on the board
and just refused to play it because of
the crazy move Queen D 5 check and she
may have thought oh my gosh I'm losing
my queen or one of my queen but now we
have King somewhere check yes and
forgotten that with a move King
somewhere check my best and White has
two queens hang which Queen to take in
fact so that was a wild turnaround at
that key moment and instead of King g4
losing to everything basically that was
guys that was absolutely incredible you
talked about not having Queens for
Queens on your board I don't remember
having four Queens on my
whatever in any game and that's that's
just simply astonishing and the reality
is that it was easy to blunder
although queens III she should have
found admittedly Queens III was a very
powerful move but she was in so much
time pressure and it's easy to blunder
and with four Queens on the board mate
could happen at any second and we saw it
did and then to blunder the way she did
was just was just really miserable but
kudos to the kid she just kept throwing
ideas at her it's up to you to find the
moves not up to me to make your good
news for you
so incredible really amazing turn of
events again she wasn't she wasn't
winning you see Camilla they're just
devastated trying to figure out what did
I do wrong and she's no look at this
point I wonder if she's gonna find he or
she knows looking at the chose this to
move let's see if she finds the Queen c3
now with no pressure on as calm as she
is now after the game she knows this is
the moment when it all happened she
probably will put Queen c3 on the board
any second guys wow this is what chess
players do they beat themselves up after
a loss or even for that matter after a
win where they where they're not pleased
with their play they go internally and
they try to look she has missed it
invited even your analysis she's
checking she's still gonna find the
right move no Queen c3 but it was so
calm complex with four Queens and you've
got to see so much it's so easy easy to
go wrong it's a big advantage for the
younger player to where she had almost
30 minutes to basically Camilla having
less than 5 minutes at the end of the
game right and on top of that I know I
shouldn't be boldly stating the obvious
but the age gap when you're young and
you've got all of this energy going for
you after five six hours of a hard
battle you start feeling it right then
even though you're young and I start
feeling it the first 20 minutes on well
we couldn't leave this broadcast without
once again interviewing a remarkable
remarkable young lady
who's sitting with Maryse and to explain
what the heck just happened what did we
just see Maurice I'm with 13 year old
master ashrita I swear on first of all
congratulations on your victory that was
an amazing game you've been treating us
too long amazing game so far and that
one was crazy
have you ever had a position with four
Queens on the board before no no we
couldn't
I can't recollect any game of mine with
four Queens so what were you thinking
when you saw the Queens coming on the
board that she was the one time so it
was easy to make a mistake but it should
have been and draw you felt that it
should have been a draw because for
Queens you know we should evaluate as a
Girona kind of typical situation it's
definitely not typical now in this
position did you miss that she could
have played this move alternatively
Queen to c3 because this would have
given you some trouble
yeah this move would have given you
trouble you thought you had Queen b1
here no Queen d1 ah Queen d1 so why it's
the track and I lose the Queen on h7
right exactly Queen d1 check and of
course this King will move out of the
way and then you're in check and your
queen is hanging so you missed that
opportunity that would have given you
some trouble but again she was in
serious time pressure so you were able
to get away with with that maneuver
earlier in the game you had
opportunities as well did you feel you
were winning and something slipped yeah
like when I allowed King takes d5
exactly and you're exactly right that
was a critical moment as well you've got
two points in the US women's
championship could you have dreamt that
after three rounds you'd be right behind
the leaders tied for third place no how
does it feel really great and really
excited I could imagine a lot of people
in California right now jumping up and
down seeing you win this game yeah she
was speechless guy well you got a rest
date tomorrow
I imagine your mom is here yeah I think
she came she did but I don't know where
she is you don't know where she is this
is a great Mother's Day gift go give her
a big hug I swear I swear on
congratulations on your victory and we
wish you the best in the rest of the
tournament
yeah guys an amazing story we're seeing
the youth movement here 13 years old
vying for first place at least right now
in third place in the US women's
championship back to you a fantastic
fantastic result and poor Camila the
flip side of the coin for every winner
somebody's lost and there's Camila still
at her board puzzling over the one that
got away
but our congratulations once again to
the Verner and thanking you very much
for joining us for our broadcast
tomorrow tomorrow 1:00 Eastern again my
mistake I probably we're in Central Time
one central we will come back to bring
you live broadcast of Round four in the
US Championships the women's will have a
free day
don't don't forget about Mother's Day
everybody and again Ben it was really
great of you Thank You Maurice happy
Mother's Day mom happy Mother's Day and
again thank you for joining us hopefully
Jennifer will be back thank you all
again Thank You Maurice
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]